[Applause]
any say in response mr. speaker how
welcome it is even joyful that for the
first time in this long song of this
house has actually accepted its
responsibilities together come together
and embraced a deal honorable members
across the house on the scale of our
collective achievement because just a
few weeks ago hardly anybody believed
that we could reopen other withdrawl let
alone abolish the backstop that is
indeed what they were saying and
certainly nobody thought that we could
secure the approval of the house for a
new deal and we should not overlook the
significance of this moment and I pay
particular tribute to those members of
the house who were skeptical and who had
difficulties and diets and who decided
to place the national interest
[Applause]
the little speaker I must express my
disappointment of the house has again
voted for delay rather than a timetable
that would have guaranteed that the UK
would be in a position to leave the EU
on October the 31st with a deal and we
now face further uncertainty and the EU
must now make up their minds are over
how to answer Parliament's request for a
delay and the first consequence mr.
speaker is that the government must take
the only responsible course and
accelerate our preparations for a No
Deal okay I will speak I will speak to
you member states about their intentions
until they have reached a decision until
we have reached a certain item say we
will pause this legislation and let me
let me be clear let me be clear our
policy remains that we should not delay
that we should leave the EU on October
the 31st
that is what I will say to the EU and I
will report back to the house and one
way or another we will leave the EU with
this deal to which this house has just
given it's a sense across the house for
that hard-won agreement
[Applause]